i found something out recently that
completely blew me away this is
something so
massively
revolutionary to my whole thinking about
property i'm just i'm gobsmacked this is
about right to buy if you have a right
to buy on a house you cannot not watch
this video if you have a right to buy on
a house and you don't watch this video
or if you know someone that has one or
if you know someone that might have one
and you don't watch this video you
deserve to be punched in the face and
you deserve to be broke for the rest of
your life okay let me explain something
okay it's right to buy is when you've
lived in a house
the house is a council house and you've
been renting this house
if you're renting a council house or a
council flat maybe in london or whatever
the council
give you
a right to buy the house and they have a
discount this is being banned by the way
this has been scrapped they've scrapped
this in scotland they're scrapping this
in wales this is just in england right
now
you have the option the right the op not
the obligation but the option to buy the
house at a discount the longer you've
lived in the house maybe you already
know this part this isn't the shocking
part it gets shocking in a minute the
longer you've lived in the house
the more you can get the house
discounted so if you've ridden the house
like 10 years i know maybe you get like
a 50 discount i've met so many people
that say oh i've got this council flat
in london it's worth 200 grand i've got
the option to buy it for 90 grand
i'm like what
you can buy it 50 or more below market
value what are you doing then go ahead
and buy it and they say this they say i
ain't got the money i haven't got the
money to buy it
and i'm like okay can't you find the
money samuel is tough man i'm gonna wait
however this is what i found out
recently this changes everything
there are lenders out there
okay there are lenders that will let you
use the discount
as the deposit
do you understand what that means
that means that if you have a house
that's worth 200 grand
and you've got the right to buy you've
got the right to buy for a 150 grand
just 50 grand discount
there are lenders that will let you use
the discount
they'll let you use the discount
as the deposit
meaning that if you've got a right to
buy
you can just buy the house
for nothing
and people are sitting on their right to
buy houses
thinking i can't afford it there was one
lady i met recently i met a lady she
said i can't afford it i introduced her
to my mortgage lending broker who said
we can just put the discount as the
deposit
student of mine she's got a property
it's basically she's got the right to
buy it it's a um she's doing it for 11
years it's a council house it's worth
180 000 pounds but she's got the right
to buy for 67 and a half thousand
okay so i've told her just to just buy
it and stop messing around and get it
like now
um question
do do you do mortgages for properties
like that
oh yeah
yeah good what deposit joey speaking i
mean she's doing full-time work and
stuff the salary is
23 23 000 pounds a year
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay one second
which
[Music]
and stuff like that and you can get your
wrap job get the mortgage assuming that
she's got the 23 yeah okay
okay
that's great i'll give you a call back
on monday and we'll get that wrapped up
and people don't know this
that means that
let me explain let's say you've got a
house that's worth 200 grand and you
have the option to buy it for 150.
that's a 50 000 pound discount
normally if you're buying it for 200
grams you'd have to put down maybe a 25
deposit but with right to buy they'll
let you use the discount as the deposit
what also with right to buy you don't
have to live in it you can rent it out
it doesn't have to be a new build or
there's it's not like the help to buy
all these restrictions as long as you
don't set it straight away if you wait
five years you can sell it
cash in
you can refinance it you can use the
deposit as the discount as the deposit
so the only thing that you have to pay
for
is the legal fees
which might be a grand or two and this
lady i was with recently she said i
can't even afford the legal fees i said
if you can't even afford the legal fees
and you're prepared to
walk away from a house let me put the
money in for the legal fees like i don't
care if it's a loan or if it's a gift
just let me put the money in and i'm
gonna say this right now as well to you
if you know someone
who's got a right to buy but they can't
buy it even though they can use the
discount as their deposit but they're so
freaking broke that they can't buy it
because they can't afford the legal fees
hit me up on instagram i'll put the
freaking money in
i'll just put the money in
okay because i'm not having people
walking away from free houses because
they can't afford the legal fees it's
just crazy so share this video all
across london share this with your
friends and family and let everybody
with a right to buy discount that can't
buy it because they can't put the legal
fees in let me put that money down okay
because i'm just i'm dying here because
what's going to happen is when they
don't buy the property and the right to
buy finishes or expires or whatever or
they move out and move on
they're gonna look back for the whole
rest of their lives and kick themselves
so hit me up let me know now let me put
that money in share this video around
man let's get some let's get some people
buying some houses this year let's get
that dip done this year i might have to
take this video down soon if i get too
many people messaging me um
the next day or two so get this shared
fast with your loved ones let's make
some stuff happen
bye
[Music]